all right matt you say how to talk to
friends who are getting engaged to train
wrecks
yes sir can you hear me okay so you're
so you're trying to red pill a buddy
that's about to get married to who bob's
married to basically is what you're
saying
yeah basically so i have a friend i was
out at new year's eve party with them
maybe four years ago and we started
talking about our
bank accounts he bought his charles
schwab account you know 25 million
dollars
and i was like no way dude like most
humble guy ever
yeah and um anyway so down the road he
gets engaged to this girl
and they just move across the country
and there's like no best man that's
getting their wedding that's coming up
in september
um he doesn't have any
25-24
wow
okay so the first girl that touched his
peepee he just you just fell head over
heels for yeah basically um she's a
pastor
and uh they just moved across the
country and she's stolen
she's 27.
so she's older
she's older she's older considerably
older
yeah um i would just honestly man you
know in the past i would say do this
that and the other thing maybe you'll
get to him that way but i'd never see it
go through so in all in all honestly
read them you know read them your last
rites and uh say hey you know it's been
good to know you
um good luck with that marriage
so i got one other funny story so
my other friend he is just proposed to a
woman who's 45 and he's also my age 25.
oh my god um
she
bought she bought him a a ram trx
so
okay it's because she bought him a 100
000 pickup truck
those things have like 707 horsepower
yeah i've driven it it's a beast
they're ridiculous man they sound
awesome
yeah i i was out there fourth of july i
picked mine anyway so he's got a sugar
mama that buys him a pickup truck yeah i
need 700
put the ring on it
well she put a ring on it basically i
mean she probably paid for the [ __ ]
all right so what's the ask here well at
least this guy's you know got a sugar
mama that's buying him toys yeah i work
with a guy i'm trying to like you know
reach him before he like you know tries
to
you know i'm just trying to reach my
friends you know that's all i'm trying i
would i would i would show him a picture
of a post-menopausal woman
that would like find an actress primoz
pre-menopausal post-menopausal and go
hey look this is what you're signing up
for
because i mean she's right at the
precipice she might even be menopausal
like i've i've heard of women in like
their early 40s right
yeah
i left you speechless with that one huh
that's where i'm at too man i guess
that's all i got
i don't know you know chris is laughing
at that yeah but i don't know like give
her man you know like these guys
generally won't listen
genuinely like hang on hang on bob bob's
still here so bob i know that you've
been listening if a guy like matt said
to you hey bob don't get married to that
pastor or to that 45 year old woman when
you were engaged do you think that
you're like plugged in self would have
listened
i think that you have to watch a couple
weeks ago you did like a show on why
smart men don't get married and there is
zero almost almost zero maybe some tax
benefits but almost zero benefit to
signing up for a marriage contract on
the side of the man we know that i put
out the podcast you guys watched it we
all agree on that the question i have
for you though is if matt came at you
when you were engaged to your wife and
said don't marry that woman would you
have listened to him or would you have
told him to pounce and no and i think
even some people told me just even some
like people that i met just told me like
just don't get married like if you want
to like
live with her or whatever have a
relationship but once you get married
you
screw yourself over in the marriage
contract again besides from maybe tax
benefits for a married couple there's no
there's there's nothing that that
marriage contract is going to do for
married men mango all right thanks bob
yeah
all right matt you good i'm good yeah
sorry man
read those last right got to pour one
out for my boys i guess yeah yeah you
might have to find some new friends
hey guys i really hope that you enjoyed
that short clip if you did consider
supporting the creation of content by
checking out my supplement line pinned
in the top comment below of this video
in the comments there's a link to the
unplugged alpha dot com forward slash
shop when you click through you'll be
able to land over here and the entire
lineup is broken down by category that
it performs best in estrogen metabolism
fat burning your foundational essentials
for health immune health performance and
testosterone support if you check out
with coupon code alpha 10 you'll get 10
off on your first order there's also the
option to use the subscribe and save
model or regular shipments will be sent
over to you on a regular basis and that
gives you a little bit of a discount and
your supplement facts are always broken
down over here thanks for watching i
hope you guys have an awesome day and
again check out that link it's pinned in
the top comment below in this video
peace out
you